did you guys read The New Yorker oh boy
segue lady no well not that much of a
seg because it still has to do with well
sort of not pedophilia but Weinstein you
hear about read about his army of spies
on the New Yorker so it turns out this
guy hired actual like Israeli
intelligence to go after the women who
were making allegations about him to
suppress them journalists who are about
to journalists who were gonna out him
Rose McGowan and a lot of other women's
he would he basically had it's a company
called black cube and it's a great name
it's so cool you play black so he so a
good I as a civilian hire black cube if
you had the money I'm sure but you know
at the end of the day I don't know if
I've said this before and I'm gonna
tread lightly
all right much is that Harvey Weinstein
has a disease he has a mental disease
it's sex addiction I know it's it's
abusive power is not a mental disease
no it's there's he is a bad guy I met
he's he's got all that other stuff too
but at the end of the day it's also a
treatable thing that you think it's
treatable
I mean it's treatable you know by way oh
yeah by putting the guy away and they're
wise he could if he would have done this
for the rest of his life even if he was
actively getting treatment my belief is
when you're so drunk on that power as he
was and he's going through you know
going going as far as to hire that in
like Israel yeah yeah yeah that's crazy
yeah you're right sir whatever sir right
that's beyond nothing there's nothing to
defend him about I'm just trying to look
at it in a way of if he was my uncle if
Harvey was my uncle what would I have to
do or help Bobbie forgot about the uncle
rule
this has been addressing sex with Bobby
Lee and then Stacy do Spacey - it's like
yeah I mean the people that are on the
set of house of cards
yeah are saying yeah I was telling her
in the car ago I've been on many sets
all right mm-hmm
not to brag where's the camera and I
don't know like I show I try show up
uh-huh
you know I mean I I they go could
address it go to makeup I do it uh-huh
we need you on set I go do it and I I
don't know how you get away with like
squeezing a guy's dick you know like
what what yeah it's a job right right
and then they let him do what they made
for years people just kind of go I know
oh it's Kevin Spacey that's what he does
not insane thank goodness it's coming to
light
yeah yeah yeah yeah but do you think the
doors but guys like that at Home Depot
that's a manager at Home Depot any
pleases ago everywhere that guy will get
fired right away it's because Kevin
Spacey is talented and he's a movie star
and all that stuff right you think
people go I'm afraid
yes right true yeah I'm afraid that I'll
never work again this is my dream like
other actors are like yeah that's what's
[ __ ] up about it it's like he's taking
advantage of people's dreams mm-hmm
right like a young actor who's 14 this
is what I want to do for the rest of my
life this is amazing this guy just
[ __ ] grabbed my dick right he's a man
he's a lot of power right if I say
anything I can get I'm never gonna work
again so they they get surprised that's
[ __ ] up brothers right and at the end
of the day here's the message of the end
of the show here's the message don't do
it brain could be gay you could jerk off
yeah yeah just put your dick into cruise
ship you really understand the
complexity
you know what yeah I don't like your
tone there
[Music]